اعلن المركز الوطني للارصاد في السعوديه
عن اعلى كميه امطار على مدينه جده وذلك من
ال8:00 صباحا وحتى الثانيه من بعد ظهر
اليوم والتي بلغت 1099 ملم المركز اوضح من
خلال التقرير الذي اصدره ان كميه الامطار
التي هطلت اليوم على جده تتجاوز كميه
الامطار المسجله في عام 2009
[موسيقى]
جدا متحدث باسم المركز الوطني للارصاد
حسين القحطاني سيد حسين مرحبا بك معي في
نشره الرابعه من الرياض بدايه هل كنتم على
علم او توقع مؤكد ل هطول هذه الكميه
الكبيره من الامطار على محافظه جده
والسيول المنقوله تشمل معظم مناطق المملكه
واشارت بشكل واضح الى منطقه مكه مكرمه
وسواحلها تشمل محافظه جده التي سجلت اليوم
امطار غزيره واستمر
ت حتى يعني متاخره من قبل قليل يعني وما
زالت الفرصه ايضا مهياه
الامطار التي هطلت على جده اليوم هي اعلى
من كميات الامطار التي هطلت على ذات
المدينه في عام 2009 ونهايه 2008
حتى الان على جده ب 179 مللي في المناطق
الجنوبيه ولكنها تفاوته في المناطق الشمال
حيث سجلنا في مصر مطار الملك عبد العزيز
حوالي 83 الى 84 مليمتر لكن اعلى كميه
امطار كانت في المناطق الجنوبيه لمحافظه
جده وبلغت تجاوزت ال 179 همم وهي اعلى
كميه امطار مسجله همم مقارنه بالامطار
التي سجلناها في 2009 و20 2011 منذ متى
بدات تنسيق مع الجهات المعنيه في همم جده
سواء مع ال- ال- المحافظه طبعا وتحدث عن
الامانه الدفاع المدني وغيرها من الجهات
المعنيه منذ اي وقت قبل هطول هذه الامطار
نعم بلا شك هناك اليه متبعه مع الجهاز ذات
العلاقه التي تتعامل ميدانيه مع الظواهر
الجويه هذه الاهليه لديها اطار زمني واطار
معلوماتي ويتم التنسيق من خلالها منذ وقت
مبكرا حتى تقوم هذه الجهات باتحاد
الاجراءات الميدانيه وخطوطها المناسبه للت
عامل
وقت مبكر
الى متى ستستمر هذه الحاله حسب
التقديراتكم في المركز الوطني
نعم حقيقه ما زال المركز الوطني للارصاد
يشير الى ان الفرصه ما زالت معيا والحاله
الحاله المطريه قد تكون تستمر معنا حتى
يوم الغد ولكنها قد تتفاوت اما كانت عليه
اليوم
ستتكرر في مدن ومحافظات اخرى في السعوديه
خلال الايام القادمه
[موسيقى]
ساعات القادمه او حتى يوم الغد هناك فرصه
مهمه ولكنها لن تكون بنفس المعدلات التي
هطلت
اه يعني ستختلف ستقل هذه
الكميه من الامطار يعني حسب التوقعات لن
تواجه جدا يعني هذا السيناريو 179 ملم
اللي كان طبعا حسب التقديرات هو الاعلى من
دول 2009 تقريبا
24 ساعه من المركز الوطني لتقديم كل
الاحتمالات التي يمكن ان تكون على هذه
الظاهره سواكر على محافظه جده
يعني بالصور والفيديوهات اللي احنا
تابعناها اكثر المناطق اللي لها الامطار
وتركزت فيها الامطار والسحب والركاميه هي
جنوب شرق جده ليس كذلك سيد حسين
يا عم ايضا شمال جده يعني كميه الامطار في
الشمال جده سجلنا اعلى من 84% وهي ايضا
معدلات ليست بسيطه يعني لانه اول مره تسجل
في الحاله ايضا معدلات عاليه يعني تمام 83
في فتره زمنيه يعني سجلنا في الساعات
الاولى ما بين الساعه الثامنه الى الساعه
بصباح
ا مرصد مطار الملك عبد العزيز كان 60 ملي
ثم ارتفع عليه كميه الامطار مع بعد ذلك
بالنسبه للمطار جده هل تؤثر هذه الحاله
على حركه همم الملاحه الجويه خلال الساعات
همم القادمه
حقيقه المركز الوطني للارصاد معني بتقديم
هذه المعلومات ومستوى الحاله وشدتها
والجهه المعنيه في المصادر اتخذ الاجراءات
المعنيه بذلك هل ازاله الحاله حاله انذار
مبكر او اصبحت انذار متقدم
اشكرك جزيل الشكر من جدا ومتحدث باسم
المركز الوطني للارصاد حسين القحطاني
متحدث باسم امانه محافظه جده محمد البقمي
سيد محمد مرحبا بك معي في هذه النشره بعد
هذه الصوره التي تكررت وتتكرر دائما مع كل
همم موسم ابطال غزيره او حتى متوسطه في
جده يعني شاهدنا غرق الشوارع الرئيسيه
واغلاق عدد من الشوارع المهمه الكباري
الانفاق الاحياء التي
غرقت سيارات التي يعني تراكمات في هذه
الاحياء وكاننا مره اخرى نعود الى
نفسناريو 2009 ما الذي حدث
الذي حدث في 2009 كان مستوى الامطار 2011
70 مل الى 111 مل
الامطار اللي تعرضت لها مدينه جده جده هذا
اليوم همم بلغت كميه الامطار نحو 180 مللي
واستمرت لنحو 8 ساعات متواصله لكن بفضل
الله ثم بفضل الانشاء السدود 15 سنه
شرق المدينه ساهمت في تخفيف الاضرار الحمد
لله
محمد الحديث عن المشاريع التي كانت همم
خططتم لها ايضا اعلنتم ايضا عن تنفيذ
بعضها منذ 2000 2019 تحدث عن مشاريع تصريف
الامطار تجمعات المياه ايضا ما الذي حدث
فيها هل تمت هذه المشاريع هل توقفت لان
الصوره التي نشاهدها تقول بان المشكله
تتكرر مره اخرى
حقيقه مثل ما ذكرت لك يعني لو قارن بين
حجم وكميه المياه التي هطلت الان او اليوم
وكميه المياه التي هطلت في السابق اليها
ثلاثه اضعاف يمكن في 2009 لكن الحمد لله
المشاهد اللي في 2009 والكارثه اللي حصلت
في 2009 لم تتكرر
في ما يخص المشاري
انا يعني كارثه ال- ال- اللي حدث في
الاحياء في الطرق الرئيسيه في اغلاقها في
جنوب جده في شرق جده قبل قليل ايضا حتى
يتحدث المتحدث الرسمي بانها ايضا حتى في
شمال جده كميه الامطار فيها عاليه
وبالتالي صار في اغلاق طرق في في في شمال
جده وبعض الاحياء المهمه ايضا صحيح
مبلغ يعني كميه كبيره
الحج من همم الاغراض
كانت المنطقه
لحظنا ان سدود ساهمت بشكل كبير
جدا
واحياء ايضا غمره
مثل ما نعرف شبكه المياه الامطار
في المدينه لا تتجاوز 20%
من
عيار المدينه
تغطيه المدينه تم الانتهاء من 10 مشاريع
مشاري سيدنا محمد
موجوده واعلنا عنها في موقع الامانه في
جميع وسائل الاعلام من ضمنها العربيه
نشرتها هذه المشاريع في البنوك يعني وين
تركزت هذه المشاريع
اماكن ذات الاولويه ولا ما اقصر الحرجه
اللي تكثر فيها التجمعات المياه وتتكرر
فيها تجمعات المياه
جدا واكثر مناطق اللي تعرضت اليوم
التجمعات المياه الامطار الشوارع اللي
غرقت فيها الاحياء ايضا كذلك اغلاق
السيارات والانفاقه غير كانت في جده
طبعا المشاريع لم تكتمل حتى الان ااا في
مشاريع جاري تنفيذها اما في ما يخص
المناطق التي لا يوجد فيها شبكه تصريح
بالمياه الامطار وضعت الامانه خطه بان
خلال 16 بلديه فرعيه تم توزيع اكثر من
2500عامل وموظف
و960 اليه ومعده
الهدف من هذه انه سحب المياه وتسهيل حركه
التنقل داخل المدينه الاعمال مستمره اللي
هي رفع اضرار المياه
كل الجهه المعنيه واكيد انتم من احد واهم
هذه الجهاد بهذه الحاله منذ وقت مبكر
تتحدثون عن الخطه اللي انت وضعتها للتعامل
مع هذا الموسم الامطار والخطه اللي
بتتعاملوا مع مع اليوم ايضا متى بدات كيف
كانت رؤوس اللي تنفذ ايضا حتى منها
تم نشر لجميع الفرق على المواقع في نطاق
16 بلديه فرعيه
بشرت الفرق اعمالها جاري سحب المياه ورفع
الانقاض الناتجه عن الحاله المطريه
والاعمال المستمره ان شاء الله
مناطق في الجنوب وفي شرق جده ايضا وقلتوا
انها مناطق جريان سيول ايضا وكان فيها
مناطق ايقاف اعطاء رخص البناء وغيره وصار
عليها المناطق
مثل ما ذكرته التي تم تنفيذ 15 سد هذه
السدود اساهمت في منع المياه المنقوله ان
تصل الى المدينه والحمد لله مثل ما ذكرت
لك يعني نسبه المياه وكميه المياه الكبيره
لم تلحق الضرر الذي حدث في عام 2009 او
الذي حدث في عام 2011
انتم فعلا اوقفتم اعطاء الرخص فيها بازلت
فيها الاحياء اللي موجوده مناطق جراين
السيوله تتحدث في الجنوب في الشرق
ولم تعطوا فيها رخص لم تعد الرخص لها مره
اخرى
طيب انا اشكرك جزيل الشكر على كل هذه
المعلومات المتحدث باسم امانه محافظه جده
السيد محمد البقمي في جده اتحول الى سلطان
السلم بمراسل العربيه السلطان مرحبا بك
معي في نشره الرابعه من الرياض تتواجد في
شرق جده كيف تصف صوره ومشهد جدا منذ صباح
حتى الان سلطان
اهلا بك نايف واهلا بكافه مشاهدي قناه
العربيه بالفعل منذ ساعات الصباح نحن
نتجول داخل الاحياء وسط وشرق وجنوب امام
محافظه جده كميه كبيره من المياه الخاصه
بالامطار وجريان السيول المنقوله وخصوصا
في مناطق شرق جدا اتحدثون عن حي الحرازات
وكذلك حي الصواعد وايضا اجزاء كبيره من حي
ابراج الرغامه فيما يتعلق في منطقه
الجنوبيه نتحدث على الاسكان وكذلك حي
السنابل والمناطق الاخرى مثل منطقه الخمره
وحي الفضيله وغيرها من الاحياء الجنوبيه
التي تضررت بشكل مباشر جدا شاهدنا ورصدنا
عدد كبير من المكارات التي يعني اصبحت
تالفه بشكل كبير جراء جريان المياه لها
ايضا تحدث على بعض عدد كبير من المنازل
التي تضررت بشكل مباشر من خلال دخول
المياه الى الاحوشه الخاصه بها وكذلك دخول
المياه عبر الاسقف الخاصه بالمنازل ان هيك
كان حالات الاحتجاز العديده التي بشرتها
فرق الدفاع المدني وك كحالات الماس
الكهربائي التي عملت عليها فرقه الدفاع
المدني وكذلك الشركه السعوديه للكهرباء في
الناحيه الاخرى انتقلنا في وسط جده تحدث
على شارقه على خط الحرمين الشريان الرئيس
الذي يربط بين شمال وجنوب جدا تم اغلاقه
بالكامل في تمام الساعه 9:00 صباحا نتحدث
على مناطق اخرى مثل الخط الذي يربط بين
مكه وجده والخط السريع تم اغلاقه بالكامل
جراء جريان البياه الكبير في هذه المناطق
ايضا فيما يتعلق بالخطوط الرئيسيه التي
تربط بين الشرق وغرب همم جده نتحدث على
نفقه شارع الستين والسبعين وكذلك شارع
صاري وبعض الميادين الكبرى هذه الميادين
اغلقت بالكامل جرائم امتلائها بالمياه
تعمل فرقه همم الامانه والدفاع المدني في
هذه المواقع بشكل همم كم مكثف وكبير جدا
لشفط المياه ايضا الهلال الاحمر السعودي
بشر همم بشكل كبير جدا حالات احتجاج تم
همم مباشره وكذلك كانت عندها مركز
العمليات التي يستقبل بشكل متواصل
البلاغات من قبل المواطنين والمقيمين
اتواجد حاليا في حي النخيل هذا الحي الذي
وهو يعتبر من مناطق الشرق جده نتحدث على
مجرى رئيسي يقع بالقرب من هذه المنطقه وهو
ممتلئ بالكامل بالمياه نتحدث على اضرار
كبيره لاحقت بالبيوت والمنازل وايضا
المركبات الخاصه في المواقفه وحتى المواقف
الجانبيه الخاصه بالاحياء السكنيه الكل من
السكان والمقيمين اليوم كان يعيش حاله دعر
كبيره اتجاه هذه المياه او التي وصلت
نسبتها الى 179 مللي هذا رقم كبير جدا
اليوم شاهدنا في مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي
وكذلك من خلال رصدنا الميداني حالات
احتجاج كبيره انقطاع الكهرباء في عدد كبير
من احياء جنوب وشرق محافظه جده الاسيه من
هذه المناطق ليست مزوده في شبكات تصريف
المياه او مغطاه يا سلطان انت من تواجدك
في هذه المناطق ما الذي تغير في شبكات
تصريف المياه يعني قبل قليل المتحدث باسم
الامانه يقول بان هناك مشاريع نفذت مشاريع
تم الانتهاء منها ومشاريع لازال العمل
عليها حتى هذه اللحظه حيث انت وحيث رصدت
هل تغير شيء في هذه المشاريع هل هي ملموسه
امامك
الصوره الصوره زميلي نايف ابلغ من الكلام
اليوم لما نشاهد يعني تصاريحها وبيانات
صحفيه تؤكد وجود مشاريع تصاريح تصريف
للمياه ولكن الواقع مختلف والصوره مختلفه
من خلال مشاهدات ومرصدته الكاميرا العربيه
ولا اللقطات التي انتشرت في كافه مواقع
التواصل الاجتماعي من خلال امتلاء هذه
الانفاق بشكل كبير جدا بالمياه وتم
اغلاقها ووجود كذلك اليات الشطه الخاصه
بامانه جده وفرق الدفاع المدني التي تعمل
بكامل الطاقه الاستيعابيه اليوم مشاريع
تصريف المياه الامطار التي موجوده في
انفاق محافظه جده لا تستطيع استيعاب اكثر
من 60 ملي متر لذلك المياه التي وجدت
اليوم او انهالت على جده هذه الامطار منذ
ساعات الصباح الاولى لا تستطيع هذه
المشاريع استيعاب اليوم 179 مللي رقم كبير
جدا المفترض انك تعادل مع مثل حالات هذه
من سنوات طويله جدا شهد جدا همم بعض هذه
مثل هذه الكوارث من خلال الكبيره لكن
اليوم شرايين جدا الرئيسيه هي مشلوله
بالكامل حتى هذه الساعه نعم
شكرا جزيلا لكم بالسلامه ان شاء الله من
شاركوا جدا مراسل العربيه سلطان شكرا
جزيلا لك